>> CHAD MYERS IS IN THE CNN
WEATHER CENTER TRACKING IAN'S
PATH THIS MORNING.
UPGRADED THERE TO A HURRICANE.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW AT THIS
HOUR?
>> WE THOUGH IT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY LARGE MAJOR HURRICANE IN
THE GULF OF MEXICO.
VERY FEW FLORIDIANS WILL HAVE NO
IMPACT AT ALL EVEN IF YOU'RE IN
MIAMI, THE WATER COULD BE COMING
UP INTO BISCAYNE BAY BECAUSE OF
THE WIND THAT'S GOING TO BE ON
SHORE FOR SO LONG.
RIGHT NOW IT'S A 75
MILE-PER-HOUR-STORM, BUT IT'S
FORECAST TO BECOME A MAJOR
CATEGORY 3 MAKE ING LANDFALL IN
ABOUT 20 HOURS OR SO IN WESTERN
C
CUBA.
THEN IT I TRIES TO PARALLEL THE
FLORIDA COAST.
IT YOU REMEMBER FROM LAST WEEK,
THE MODELS WERE A MESS.
NOW THEY HAVE REALLY COME
TOGETHER IN THE MIDDLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD EXPECT.
WE WILL HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF
REALLY WHICH LINE IS CORRECT.
REGARDLESS, THERE'S A BIG STORM
OUT THERE.
HERE'S THE EUROPEAN.
STILL OFFSHORE, BUT VERY, VERY
CLOSE.
EVEN WITH A BRUSHING BLOW, WE
COULD SEE THE STORM SURGE UP
HERE INTO TAMPA.
5 TO 8 FEET.
THE IRONY IS HERE.
WHEN THE STORM IS SOUTH, WIND
MAY BLOW THE WATER OUT OF TAMPA
BAY AND THEN WHEN THE STORM GOES
BY, IT WILL BLOW IT BACK IN.
THOSE ARE BIG STORM SURGES.
AND THE WAVES WITH A STORM
THAT'S GOING TO BE BLOWING AT
140 MILES PER HOUR WILL BE 25,
30 FEET.
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A REEF OPT
THE WEST COAST OF FLORIDA.
THOSE WAVES WILL BE CRASHING ON
FLORIDA.
A LOT OF RAINFALL WITH THIS.
IT'S A BIG EVENT.
COULD BE A THE FOOT OF RAIN IN
PLACES THAT AREN'T EVEN NEAR THE
CENTER.
SO A LOT OF THINGS TO GO RIGHT,
SOME THING SS TO GO WRONG.
WE'LL KEEP WATCHING IT.
WE'RE STILL A COUPLE DAYS AWAY.
BUT THE PREP DAY IS TODAY.
>> TIME TO MAKE THOSE
PREPARATION, THANK YOU.
>> JOINING US IS MICHAEL
BRENNAN, ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR NOAA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US ON THIS MORNING AS WE'RE
WATCHING IAN APPROACH HERE.
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHERE YOU ARE
WATCHING AND WHEN YOU'RE
EXPECTING LANDFALL.
>> WELL, YOU CAN SEE IAN RIGHT
NOW IS LOCATED ABOUT 90 MILES
SOUTHWEST OF GRND KAY MEN WITH
INTENSE ACTIVITY DEVELOPING NEAR
THE CENTER.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS INTENSIFY
RAPIDLY.
IF WE LOOK AT THE FORECAST NOW,
WE'RE EXPECTING IAN TO TURN FROM
ITS NORTHWESTERN MOTION AND MOVE
TOWARDS COUBA OVERNIGHT TONIGHT
AND INTO TUESDAY MORNING.
THEN WE'RE EXPECT ING A MAJOR
HURRICANE TO APPROACH THE WST
COAST OF FLORIDA DURING THE DAY
WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY.
FOR THAT REASON, NWE'RE HIGH
LIELGTING THIS AREA FROM
INGLEWOOD INCLUDING TAMPA BAY IS
NOW IN A HURRICANE WATCH.
WE ALSO HAVE A STORM SURGE WATCH
IN EFFECT FOR THE ENTIRE WEST
COAST OF THE FLORIDA PENINSULA.
SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THOSE HAZARDS DEVELOPING AS WE
GO INTO WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY
OF THIS REVON.
>> TALK TO US ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL DAMAGE HERE, HOW
STRONG THIS IS EXPECTED TO BE,
WHAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE EXPECTING.
>> WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL FOR IN TERMS OF STORM
SURGE INUNDATION OF 5 TO 8 FEET
ABOVEGROUND LEVEL.
THAT'S LIFE THREATENING STORM
SURGE.
I'M 6 FEET TALL, SO THAT'S
POTENTIALLY WATER TWO FEET ABOVE
MY HEAD.
4 TO 7 FEET OF INUNDATION IN THE
CHARLOTTE HARBOR AREA.
AND THE POTENTIAL FOR MAJOR
HURRICANE-FORCE WINDS THAT CAN
DO A LOT OF DAMAGE.
BUT WATER AND POTENTIALLY STORM
SURGE IS THE HAZARD THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO KILL THE MOST
PEOPLE IN A HURRICANE,
ESPECIALLY ALONG THE FLORIDA
WEST COAST.
>> WITH THAT CONE OF URN
UNCERTAINTY, HOW SHOULD
FLORIDIANS BE PREPARING FOR
THIS, DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY
LIVE?
>> IF YOU LIVE IN THE STORM
SEARCH WATCH AREA, ESPECIALLY IN
THIS AREA FROM CAPE CORAL UP TO
TAMPA, TODAY IS THE DAY TO PUT
YOUR PLAN INTO ACTION.
BE ON THE LOOKOUT FOR ANY
EVACUATION ORDERS OR OTHER
PREPARED NNESS INFORMATION THAT
GOING TO COME FROM LOCAL
OFFICIALS.
YOU BASICALLY HAVE TODAY AND
TOMORROW TO PREPARE AND TO
EVACUATE, IF YOU'RE ORDERED TO
DO SO.
CONDITIONS ARE GOING TO START TO
DETERIORATE INTO LATE TUESDAY,
TUESDAY NIGHT AND WEDNESDAY.
THERE'S ALSO THE POTENTIAL FOR
VERY HEAVY RAINFALL ACROSS MUCH
OF THE STATE OF FLORIDA, EVEN
INLAND AND ON THE EAST COAST.
THIS AREA IN RED FROM ORLANDO TO
TAMPA BAY IS MOST AT RISK OF
FLOODING RAIN OVER THE NEXT
THREE DAYS.
>> MICHAEL BRENNAN, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WE KNOW YOU'RE BUSY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> WITH IAN NOW FORECAST TO
REACH MAJOR HURRICANE STATUS TO
BE THE AS IT NEARS COUBA, PEOPL
THERE UNDERSTANDABLY PREPARING
AS WELL THAT'S WHERE WE FIND
PATRICK OTMAN.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
PEOPLE IN THIS AREA ARE HOLDING
THEIR BREATH TO SEE IF THE STORM
HITS THE WESTERN TIP OF CUBA OR
COMES FURTHER EAST INTO THE P
POPULATED AREAS IN HAVANA.
AND SO THE GOVERNMENT IS WARNING
PEOPLE TO BE PAYING VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION.
CERTAINLY PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
LOW-LYING AREAS WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO EVACUATE.
THE STORM IS HILTING A COUNTRY
THAT IS BATTERERED ECONOMICALLY.
SO IN TERMS OF GOING TO STOCK UP
OR BUY PLYWOOD, THOSE THINGS ARE
NOT IN THE STORE.
IF YOU LIVE IN THE ISLAND, YOU
HAVE TO HUNKER DOWN.
ALL THIS SUMMER IT'S BEEN FAIRLY
QUIET IN TERMS OF HURRICANES.
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
FLORIDA STRAITS WERE HOPING WE
WOULD GET BY WITHOUT A HURRICANE
HITTING.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
CUBA IS GOING TO GET ABSOLUTELY
HAMMERED IN THE NEXT HOURS TO
COME.
IT JUST REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WHETHER IT'S A MOSTLY RURAL AREA
WHERE THE STORM CROSSES OVER,
WHICH WOULD DO LESS DAMAGE, OR
IF YOU HAVE FLOODING, BUILDINGS
COLLAPSE, WHICH CAN HAPPEN EVEN
IF THERE ISN'T A DIRECT HIT FROM
A HURRICANE.
SO AT THIS MOMENT, THE
GOVERNMENT HERE IS TELLING
PEOPLE TO KEEP A VERY CLOSE EYE
ON WHAT COULD BE A POTENTIALLY
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS SITUATION.
>> WE'LL CONTINUE TO CHECK IN
WITH YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
CARLOS, WHAT IS HAPPENING BEHIND
YOU THERE?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
LADIES.
STORM PREPARATIONS ACROSS THE
CITY OF TAMPA ARE WELL UNDER
WAY.
WE'RE AT ONE OF THREE SANDBAG
DISTRIBUTION SITES THAT JUST GOT
UNDER WAY A FEW MINUTES AGO.
YOU CAN SEE HOW MANY FOLKS HAVE
SHOWED UP TO TRY TO FILL UP
THEIR SANDBAGS.
THE LINE TO GET TO THIS PARK
GOES ALL THE WAY DOWN THE BLOCK
AND STRETCHES ALL THE WAY TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
THE CITY, IN ANTICIPATION OF IAN
AND THE FACT WE MIGHT BE SEEING
SOME SORT OF IMPACT FROM THAT
STORM HAS BEEN TRYING TO TELL
FOLKS THAT THEY NEED TO FINISH
THEIR STORM PREPS TODAY.
THEY WANT THEM TO GO AHEAD AND
TAKE A LOOK AT THEY'RE
EVACUATION ROUTES AND WANT THEM
TO LOOK AT THE FLOOD ZONES, THE
FLOOD MAPS.
THAT'S IF THEY MAKE A DECISION
TO GO AHEAD AND STAY PUT.
THE LAST TIME THAT TAMPA WAS HIT
DIRECTLY BY A HURRICANE WAS
1921.
OFFICIALS ARE REALLY CONCERNED
THAT, IF THAT STORM MAKES ITS
WAY HERE, WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT STORM SURGE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANYWHERE
BETWEEN 6 TO 8 FEET OF A STORM
SURGE.
YOU'LL HAVE ALL THAT WATER BEING
PUSHED UP ALONG THE COAST AND
INTO THE TAMPA BAY AREA.
THE MAYOR SAID A DECISION ON
EVACUATION HASN'T BEEN MADE YET.
SHE WAS EXPECTING TO GET A
BRIEFING THIS MORNING.
WE COULD BE GETTING MORE
INFORMATION FROM HER ON THAT.
SCORES ACROSS HILLSBOROUGH
COUNTY HAVE BEEN CLOSED THROUGH
AT LEAST THURSDAY CONSIDERING
THAT A LOT OF THEIR BUILDINGS
WILL BE USED AS STORM SHELTERS.
THAT IS GIVING US AN EARLY
INDICATION IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THIS COUNTY IS MOVING FORWARD
TO, AT SOME POINT, GO AHEAD AND
ISSUE SOME SORT OF EVACUATION
ORDER FOR RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN
A PRETTY LOW LYING AREA.
>> THAT STORM SURGE THEY'RE
PREPARING FOR, WHAT EXACTLY
MIGHT THAT LOOK LIKE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BUSINESSES AND THE
HOMES IN THAT AREA?
>> Reporter: WELL, TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOWE THINGS LOOK WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW, WE'RE AT A
PARK THAT'S SURROUNDED BY THREE
BAYS, THE OLD TAMPA BAY, THE
TAMPA BAY AND THEN THAT THIRD
BAY.
WHAT THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT,
ESPECIALLY THE FOLKS IN PINELLAS
COUNTY, THAT STORM SURGE IS
GOING TO FLOOD THINGS NO MATTER
WHAT.
EVEN IF THAT FORECAST TRACK ENDS
UP HAVING IAN MOVING PARALLEL TO
TAMPA BAY AND THE TAMPA AREA,
THEY STILL BELIEVE WE'RE GOING
TO SEE A LOT OF THAT WATER
MAKING ITS WAY INLAND.
SO THEY WANT FOLKS TO GO AHEAD
AND COME OUT AND GET THESE
SANDBAGS.
THE LINES AT THESE THREE
LOCATIONS WERE PRETTY LONG.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THEY'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO THIS
TODAY AND TOMORROW AND MOST
LIKELY INTO WEDNESDAY.
HOWEVER, EMERGENCY OFFICIALS
AGAIN HAVE BEEN TELLING FOLKS,
TRY TO GET THIS DONE EARLY
BECAUSE WE COULD SEE SOME OF
THESE EFFECTS STARTING TUESDAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD ADVICE TO HEED THERE.
CARLOS, THANK YOU.